mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
wissens uci vergnügen
ganz herzlich willkommen zu einem
kulturplatz extra aus sarajevo genau
hier standen einst sieger 1984 fanden in
der metropole von bosnien herzegowina
die olympischen winterspiele statt und
wenig ist davon übrig geblieben aus
sportstadien wurden ruinen verwaiste
zeugen der vergangenheit des ehemaligen
vielvölkerstaates jugoslawien
und manche sportstätte wurde zum
kriegsschauplatz wie die bobbahn die im
bosnien krieg anfang der 1990 er jahre
stark umkämpft war von diesem berg aus
schoss die serbische armee auf die stadt
und die menschen sache - aber nicht nur
die vergangenheit ist unser thema
sarajevo steht vor immensen sozialen und
politischen herausforderungen
wir wollen wissen was kulturschaffende
tun um diese stadt zu verändern
in der die vergangenheit so sehr mit der
gegenwart verflochten ist
der sprung über den schatten wie die
bosnische kulturszene gegen die
politische erstarrung angeht
die suche nach der herkunft die
bosnische künstler in der schweiz ihre
identität hin zu fragen
die beschwörung des glücks was populäre
grabstein motive über die bosnische
gesellschaft verraten wie er in sarajevo
treffen kulturen aufeinander eine stadt
der gegensätze
und wer genau hinschaut kann geschichte
entdeckten spuren von ereignissen die
sich eingeprägt haben in unser
gedächtnis
ich nehme sie gleich mal mit auf eine
erholungsfahrt
was ist nicht alles geschehen in dieser
stadt jahreszahlen kreisen im kopf wenn
man an sarajevo denkt 19 14
1984 der bosnienkrieg anfang der 1990 er
jahre in sarajevo spiegelt sich
geschichte im licht der gegenwart
heute denkt man vor allem an 19 14 und
den ersten weltkrieg in sarajevo die
stadt des attentats in der vor 100
jahren
der österreichische thronfolger franz
ferdinand erschossen wurde hier auf
dieser burg es war nicht die ursache
aber der auslöser für den ausbruch des
ersten weltkriegs für das große
schlachten das acht millionen menschen
das leben kostet 1914 erinnert ein
kleines museum
doch das attentat hat kaum bedeutung für
die menschen hier der attentäter gavrilo
princip ist ein serbischer freiheitsheld
wen interessiert das schon im bosnischen
sarajevo im jahr 2014
dafür ist ein anderes historisches
ereignis umso bedeutsamer ein ewiges
feuer erinnert an den gründungsmythos
jugoslawiens an die befreiung von der
deutschen besetzung am ende des zweiten
weltkriegs durch die post partisanen aus
der sozialistische staat jugoslawien
entstand
1984 brennt das olympische feuer in
sarajevo es sind die ersten winterspiele
in einem sozialistischen land ein paar
jahre später im olympischen stadion
werden tote begraben opfer der
belagerung durch serbische truppen
während des bosnienkriegs
und heute fast 20 jahre nach dem krieg
der friedensvertrag von dayton hat ein
kompliziertes gebilde geschaffen einen
staat bestehend aus einer bosniakisch
kroatischen föderation und der
serbischen republik ein staat drei
präsidenten
für jede volksgruppe eine eigene
bürokratie und alle blockieren sich
gegenseitig das resultat 45 prozent
arbeitslosigkeit
sarajevo leidet an politischer und
ökonomischer lähmung gegen die sich nun
heftiger protest
seit anfang februar gibt es hier vor dem
präsidentenpalast in sarajevo jeden tag
demonstrationen gegen stillstand und
korruption von der politik denkt die
meisten hier enttäuscht aber wer weiß
vielleicht schaffen es gerade
künstlerinnen und künstler dem land neue
impulse zu geben
sechster februar 2014
ausnahmezustand in bosnien herzegowina
zum ersten mal in der geschichte des
landes protestieren die menschen gegen
die regierung mit gewalt das
ausgebrannte regierungsgebäude in
sarajevo vor ein paar tagen ein symbol
für die wut der bürger über die
wirtschaftliche misere in ihrem land wir
fragen für kulturschaffende in sarajevo
warum bosnien herzegowina nicht vom
fleck kommt und wie sie mit der
schlechten situation umgehen
die band dubioser kollektiv engagiert
sich in ihren liedern sehr stark in
politischen fragen
sie erklären warum anfang februar vor
allem junge menschen auf die straße
gingen jungen erwachsenen heute waren
anfangs der 90er jahre noch babys sie
haben den krieg nicht selber miterlebt
und sind dadurch auf eine art normaler
als die älteren generationen
die jungen finden sich heute nicht so
recht weil sie nicht verstehen worauf
denn eigentlich die gesellschaft die
ganze zeit wartet
das erbe des krieges blockiert die
menschen noch immer
auf 20 jahre nachkriegs
die theaterregisseurin selber speech
geht in ihre arbeit genau solchen
mechanismen auf den grund ich denke dass
diese kriegs thematik sehr oft
missbraucht wird um die gesellschaft im
zustand der angst zu halten und so vom
sozialen abgrund abzulenken in welchen
sich das land befindet
das überdeckt die realität weil dieser
rhetorischen hetze haben sich die leute
schließlich hauptsache wir sind am leben
und haben jeden tag ein stück brot zu
essen
das parlamentsgebäude in die rigide
machtverteilung unter den drei ethnien
bringt vor allem eines politische
lähmung
in ihrem theaterstück skip stina zu
deutsch versammlung versucht selber
spahic die absurdität dieses politischen
systems zu entlarven
dazu verwendet sie echte parlaments
protokolle der letzten 20 jahre
es geht mir um die politische
verantwortung und darum dass wir in
einem vollkommen blockierten system
liegen die gegenseitige politische
behinderung ist alltag und deshalb
entwickelt sich die gesellschaft so kaum
ich versuche mich künstlerisch mit
dieser problematik auseinanderzusetzen
ein herziges unterfangen in bosnien
herzegowina gestalte sich kultur
schaffen wie sisyphos arbeit für die
politik zumindest scheint die kultur nur
ein lästiger kostenfaktor zu sein
immer mehr kulturinstitutionen schließen
ihre türen wie zb das landesmuseum vor
drei jahren dieses mangelnde bewusstsein
für kultur ist eines der themen des
videokünstlers damit schied er begegnet
der misere seines landes mit satire wenn
der humor nicht mehr da ist dann wird
alles so ernst angehen sich die menschen
an die gurgel greifen zu messer und
gewähr
deshalb ist es gut wenn wir uns in
satire üben und uns auf diese art und
weise abreagieren in seinen tausendfach
angeklickte youtube-videos entlarvt
niksic die bornierten aus allen lagern
und zwingt die menschen so zum
nachdenken über ihre gesellschaft als
künstler kann ich dieses extreme bild
konstruieren und den leuten vorhalten
damit sie von selbst sagen
warte mal warte diese entwicklung läuft
nicht gut das ist immer noch besser als
wenn
alle in eine richtung stur weiter machen
von erst dann plötzlich kein zurück mehr
gibt in welche richtung bewegt sich die
bosnische gesellschaft heute fakt ist
das land ist immer noch zweigeteilt
ein austausch unter den größeren städten
der beiden landesteile findet kaum statt
die schauspielerin luna mijovic hat
schon in vielen nationalen und
internationalen filmen mitgespielt
zuletzt im schweizer film traum hat sie
steht für die junge generation welche
mehr kontakt und austausch mit dem
anderen landesteil einfordert man
versucht jegliche solidarität zu
unterbinden zwischen den beiden teilen
zwischen den menschen der republica
srpska und denen der föderation weil das
der politik lehrt passt denn wenn wir
eine einheit wären hätten wir die kraft
etwas in diesem land zu verändern
aber solange das verhindert wird
verbessert sich die situation nur für
die ganz unten
die von diesem zustand profitieren die
bosnier haben genug vom selbstsüchtiger
establishment und tatsächlich seit den
demonstrationen nehmen die menschen ihr
schicksal erstmal selber in die hand
jede woche tagen vielerorts autonome
volksversammlungen die unter anderem
auch über kulturpolitische themen
abstimmen
doch die demonstrationen vor dem
regierungsgebäude frauen bereits wieder
ab
es ist noch ein weiter weg in eine
bessere zukunft
trotz anhaltender krise immerhin haben
die bosnier ihren trockenen humor noch
nicht verloren
auf dem transparent steht gruppe wenn du
gegen korruption bist
eine der ältesten jüdischen friedhöfe
europas liegt in sarajevo und auch hier
findet man spuren spuren der geschichte
spuren des kriegs hier oben haben sich
die ersten snipers die ersten
scharfschützen eingenistet und zielten
auf zivilisten
ein normales leben war damals in
sarajevo undenkbar
und dennoch wurde theater gespielt und
zwar hier
das salz wird er wurde während des
kriegs gegründet über 2000 vorstellungen
und so wurde theater spielen hier jeden
abend zum akt des überlebens ich spreche
jetzt mit micha crasher jakobitsch dem
leiter des theaters die vergangenheit
ist eine schwere bürde
was können sie daraus lernen 20 jahre
nach dem krieg es ist sehr schwer
heutzutage optimistisch zu sein aber ich
versuche so gut ich kann
optimismus ist ein menschlicher zug man
sollte die welt zu sehen
deshalb glaube ich an die idee von
bosnien
es ist zwar ein kleiner staat der aber
als ganzes gesehen eine erfrischende
perspektive für europa bietet
wir haben hier eine vielfalt für die wir
kämpfen müssen
diese vielfalt ein ewigen ist ein
geschenk gottes und wir können alle
profitieren wenn wir eine welt voller
unterschiede schaffen
dazu muss man aber den vorteil der
unterschiede erkennen und freude daran
haben
anstatt sich gegenseitig zu hassen weil
man anders ist aber wie kann man diese
feindschaften überwinden
das wichtigste ist eine normale
kommunikation unter den leuten zu
schaffen in bosnien sind die ethnischen
stereotypen der große fall deshalb
müssen wir auch verständigung haben
es ist viel ehrlicher zuzugeben dass man
heute mit seinen nachbarn probleme hat
weil sie die stadt vier jahre lang
belagert und versucht haben mich und
meine freunde umzubringen
nur weil er den falschen namen hatten
oder am falschen ort lebten
das werde ich so schnell nicht vergessen
geschweige denn verzeihen aber nur das
gespräch
die auseinandersetzung für all diese
themen wird andere verhältnisse schaffen
das wäre der erste schritt in eine
bessere zukunft
die welt hat wir erwarten
viele menschen sind damals aus bosnien
weggezogen sei es wegen des krieges oder
auch aus anderen gründen
sie haben ein neues leben begonnen haben
familien gegründet und leben auch mitten
unter uns in der schweiz
wir haben zwei künstler der secondo
generation getroffen und sie gefragt mit
welchen themen sie sich
auseinandersetzen
und was für sie heimat bedeutet koran
ghalib 36 geboren in der schweiz als
sohn bosnischer serben für seine
abschlussarbeit an der hochschule der
künste besucht er ab 2001 mit einem
freund mehrmals die heimat der eltern
er dokumentiert diese reisen ausführlich
mit einem fotobuch texten karten und
videomaterial
es war der versuch die bilder aus
kindertagen mit denen aus den medien zu
vereinbaren sagt er
eine wahrheitsfindung vor ort sozusagen
unter druck
zum blog posten beschuss
was der fotograf vorfindet ist
überraschend verstörend
da ist etwa eva gleichen aus
massengräbern birgt und trotzdem einen
fröhlichen eindruck macht von der reise
nach kuba einer hochburg der
nationalisten wird ihm abgeraten
im textbuch beschreibt er diese anekdote
der mann fragte mich ob ich serbe sei
eigentlich bin ich bosnier antwortete
ich verunsichert dass sprache zu mir zu
einem kind in bosnien gibt es keine
bosniern kroaten serben und moslems
koran der secondo aus der schweiz der
jugoslawien und bosnien nur von ferien
besuchen kannte musste plötzlich
position beziehen und fühlte sich durch
seine herkunft stigmatisiert flacht die
entwicklung im revier wenig wie so neu
verteilt wurde und das ist denn die
bevölkerungsgruppe am meisten als täter
beschuldigt worden ist und ich habe mich
denn auch betroffen gefühlt obwohl ich
absolute mit ca
der künstler wehrt sich mit seiner
arbeit gegen schubladisierung und
schuldzuweisungen
die fotos haben keine legende die karten
benennen keine ortschaften
die botschaft ist klar bosnien könnte
überall sein
daniela janjic 30 sie ist sieben als die
familie aus bosnien flieht über umwege
landet sie in der schweiz dem krieg
entkommt sie doch der konflikt verfolgt
sie weiterhin und prägt ihr ganzes
schaffen
auch sie versucht die reduktion auf die
herkunft zu verhindern indem sie weder
namen noch orte nennt in ihrem zweiten
theaterstück tod meiner stadt geht es um
vergangenheitsbewältigung und neuanfang
die mutter die mit ihrem neuen freund im
westen lebt holt den sohn nach weg von
der kriegsversehrten heimat weg vom
vater einem soldaten die
autobiografische elemente sind klar
erkennbar
jan jetzt geht es aber nicht um die
verarbeitung der eigenen geschichte
vielmehr ist sie an den mechanismen
interessiert die in solchen konflikten
spielen
das ist auch die arctic sea im inneren
kindheits show das ohne dass ich einmal
kaufen oder so ist für mich politisch
immer schon automatisch privat tod
meiner stadt thematisiert auch die
verarbeitung von altlasten in der ferne
erfährt der sohn eines tages dass sein
vater an kriegsverbrechen in der eigenen
familie beteiligt war
auch in den kindheitserinnerungen hat
sich die verflechtung von politik und
privatem festgesetzt
als überzeugte sozialisten schwenken die
eltern zur heirat die jugoslawische
nationalflagge und am ersten mai wird
die stärke des vaterlandes zelebriert
der sozialismus spielte auch in luzern
eine wichtige rolle
weiter ab von titus machtbereich labor
andric mitglied der jungpioniere die
herkunft verweist sowohl auf bosnien wie
auf jugoslawien die beschreibung von
heimat und identität fällt entsprechend
schwer
nestwärme gespürt ich versage
du hast das magisch wie zwei
heimatländer und mein geschmack
man sieht es zwar nicht aber hier
befinde ich mich auf einer grenze hier
ist der kroatisch bosniakische teil von
sarajevo da drüben beginnt die republica
srpska der von serben dominierte teil
des landes ein staat also aber trotzdem
grenzen und die sind vor allem in den
köpfen der menschen zu finden
nicht aber im kopf des künstlers laden
miljanovic
er überwindet das bild das sich von
bosnien eingeprägt hat auch mladen
miljanovic hat angehörige im krieg
verloren aber er sucht auf dem friedhof
nicht nach toten sondern nach
darstellungen des lebens
besonders gern hat der künstler
friedhöfe wo muslime juden und christen
einträchtig beieinander liegen hier
sammelt er abbildungen davon wie die
verstorbenen in erinnerung bleiben
sollten was sie glücklich macht was ihre
wünsche waren der wunsch nach freude ist
teil unseres genetischen codes mehr
verwischt alle unsere gewohnten
unterscheidungen nach religionen oder
ideologie der friedhof ist ein raum frei
von ideologischen denke dieses
unkontrollierte macht es echt und
wahrhaftig
der 33 jährige arbeitete früher als
steinmetz ein krisensicherer job der ihn
zur kunst brachte
und letztes jahr als ersten vertreter
bosniens seit zehn jahren an die
biennale in venedig jene ausstellung ist
nun in der nationalgalerie in sarajevo
zu sehen der garden of delight der
garten der freude
herzstück ist ein triptychon aus stein
links das paradies ein altes paar
rechts die hölle ohne menschen nur
maschinen
dazwischen die gegenwart über 100
grabstein motive mit idealisierten
porträts auffallend die vielfalt darin
aber auch die gegensätze prallen klassen
und religionen aufeinander
hier geschieht der zusammenprall auf
vielen ebenen die unterschiedlichen
einflüsse und wünsche sind teil unserer
realität
deshalb denke ich dass diese arbeit die
identitäten der region abbildet ein
garten ist nur schön wenn verschiedene
blumen blühen
liebe freunde
was würdet ihr gern im pavillon von
bosnien herzegowina in venedig sehen
diese frage stellte der künstler im
vorfeld der biennale
die sms antworten sind in stein graviert
wie schwer er an all den wünschen und
erwartungen seines landes trägt das
demonstrierte media novica an der
eröffnung den stein in den händen tragen
zeigt die schöne landschaft von bosnien
zeigt die schöne seite von uns die leute
reden von gutem essen und trinken
hauptsache keine politik nichts mit
ethnien nichts mit krieg doch auf den
grabsteinen ist das militär sehr präsent
das steckt tief in der gesellschaft hin
aber da geht es nicht nur um gewalt und
konflikt sondern auch an tradition
mein urgroßvater bei der preußischen
front er war in österreichisch
ungarischer soldat
mein großvater war partisan im zweiten
weltkrieg
mein vater war im letzten krieg dann war
es an mir was würde ich sein
der bosnische serbe milliarde zwar
selber soldat hier in banja luka der
hauptstadt der serbischen republik
bosnien
heute unterrichtet der sohn eines
arbeiters kunst studierende in einer
ehemaligen militärkaserne hier hielt
auch radovan karadzic reden für den
optimisten ist die umnutzung des
gebäudes zeichen dass veränderungen zum
besseren möglich sind aber nur ganz
starke wünsche
davon ist er überzeugt können realität
werden mein größter wunsch für bosnien
oder er für die menschen die hier leben
dass sie sich über ihre eigenen wünsche
klar werden und über bessere
lebensbedingungen nachdenken dass sie
ihr leben nicht nach politisch
ideologischer befriedigung ausrichten
sondern nach persönlicher an diesem ort
wird klar tradition und freies denken
schließen sich nicht aus
wir sind am ende unserer reise
angekommen hier beim sehr viele brunnen
in der altstadt von sarajevo wer von
diesem brunnen trinkt heißt dass wir
wiederkommen ich nehme einen schluck wir
sehen uns nächste woche wieder tschüss
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur des
wissens